Do you ever find yourself wishing that you
could speed up time or slow down time?
Guess what, you totally can!
Kind of.
Hey everyone, Laci Green here and this is
Dnews.
Time is a fixed dimension.
One second for me is one second for you.
But even though one second is fixed, how we
experience it and perceive it can vary hugely.
And that's because our brains aren't just
keeping track of time, watching it go by,
our brains are actively constructing time
- creating time.
I know, "Whoa dude that's so crazy!"
That tidbit comes from David Eagleman, a neuroscientist
and director of the Eagleman Laboratory for
Time and Perception.
He says he became fascinated with time when
as a child he fell off a roof.
And he kept falling, and falling, and falling.
And in those moments, it felt like time had
completely slowed down.
Mid-air he thought to himself, "This is what
Alice must have felt like falling down the
rabbit hole."
There are a few things that we know about
our mind's perception of time.
Unlike our senses like touch and taste, time
doesn't have a specific part in the brain
that controls the perception of it.
Time comes down to a whole complex network
of areas within the brain.
We also know that when we're in a life threatening
situation, time seems to slow down.
And as we get older, time seems to speed up.
Neuroscientist have pieced together why this
is so.
The more information your brain has to process,
the slower time seems.
When you're in a life threatening situation,
all of your brain's resources have become
intensely focused on survival.
You're paying really close attention.
The more attention to detail there is, the
longer time seems to last because all of that
information takes longer for your brain to
process.
On the flipside, time goes faster when you
don't have much information to process.
If you're not taking in much that's new, your
brain is on autopilot.
Less resources required, and time feels faster.
This explains why time seems to get faster
as we get older.
As you age, there isn't as much new information
for your brain to take in, which creates shortcuts
in your brain.
Ok.
Cool.
So what about when time goes really slow when
you're bored?
A study in the Journal of Consumer Psychology
found that without enough stimulation, the
brain concentrates its resources on monitoring
the time.
You're like, "Come on, tick tock."
And because it consumes your brain, you perceive
it as slower.
On the flipside, a study published by The
Association For Psychological Science found
that people don't actually perceive time as
shorter when they're having fun.
But people did report more enjoyment when
they were lied to and told the task they performed
took half the time than they actually took.
So what this all means is that we do have
some control over our perception of time.
We can make it seem faster by finding ways
to distract ourselves from the passage of
time, and we can slow it down when things
seem too fast, by giving our brains lots of
new things to process.
Continuing to learn new things and chewing
on new ideas and immersing yourself in new
environments.
So, there you go time benders.
Go do your thing.
I'll see you next time with more Dnews.
And don't forget to like our Facebook page
for more crazy science updates.